ich habe diese Pfanne mit Spülmaschine
und spülen nicht sauber bekommen aber
angeblich hilft Backpulver und Zitrone
wir probieren das ganze einfach mal aus
ich und ihr habt das bestimmt schon ein
paar mal auf tiktok gesehen dass das
angeblich super gut funktionieren soll
das Ding ist ich habe die Pfanne
wirklich nicht sauber bekommen also wenn
das jetzt klappt wäre schon sehr sehr
nice ohne halbieren und dann einfach den
Saft drauf pressen geht auf jeden Fall
direkt runter hier wenn das jetzt
funktioniert hat sich auf jeden Fall
einmal mehr gelohnt dass ich die App
runtergeladen habe so das ganze stand
jetzt zwei drei Minuten ich versuche
jetzt mit der gleichen Bürste mit der
ich schon mit Spüli vergeblich versucht
habe das sauber zu bekommen
uff da tut sich wirklich was geil okay
ich habe wirklich alles gegeben wir
spielen das jetzt einmal aus und dann
gucken ob es funktioniert hat okay Leute
ich weiß nicht warum ich mich so freue
aber guckt euch das mal bitte an es ist
wirklich perfekt sauber geworden ich
kann mich gefühlt darin spiegeln und ich
weiß welches ein bisschen dumm weil ihr
das euer Leben lang schon kennt aber
diese Pfanne kann ich jetzt endlich
wieder benutzen sehr gut